[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans le premier supermarché du
plateau de saclay donc notre supermarché
franprix qui a ouvert il ya un peu plus
d'un an donc au mois d'avril 2010 9
on a une clientèle donc je pense à 80%
étudiante et on a aussi une clientèle de
bureau avec toutes les entreprises qu'on
a autour de notre site
aujourd'hui sur deuxième confinement on
a pu rester ouverts avec avec notre
voisin le boulanger on se sent un peu
moins seul on espère que l'ensemble du
plateau va se remplir
après après les fêtes de fin d'année et
retrouver un petit peu toute cette vie
sur le plateau qu'on apprécie tant
c'est d'abord une histoire de famille
clairement c'est comme ça que grand père
il appelait qu'on est également sur la
place du village et l'envoyer un coup de
clairon pour nous dire à table on a tous
types de clients
on arrive à être à iso périmètre à peu
près de services qu'avant de confinement
on a la chance d'aller ce conte et
mobiles l'année vers l'opportunité de
garder nos sites et de garder à peu près
le même type de service qu'avant
[Musique]
living room a été créée le 22 août l'an
dernier en 2019
c'est un restaurant traditionnel avec
des fruits de mer des viandes des
poissons
on essaye vraiment de faire dans
palaiseau un restaurant chic agréable et
efficace sans pour autant les sur paris
pour noël on a envie de se faire plaisir
malgré confinement et tous les problèmes
qu'on a je vais proposer des plateaux de
fruits de mer que vous pourrez commander
sur notre site internet ou par téléphone
jusqu'au 22 décembre des plateaux de
fruits de mer sur mesure donc faites
travailler vos commerces de proximité
parce que franchement on en a mais
vraiment vous en
[Musique]
ici on est à l'adagio access palaiseau
saclay c'est un hôtel qui a ouvert en
janvier 2019
cette année 2020 qui doit être
excellente vue le départ qu'on allait
chez en janvier et février
malheureusement connu le coc vide
maintenant janvier on aimerait bien que
tout s'arrête et que tout reprenne ce
que nous on est prêts c'est une deuxième
année d'ouverture c'est dommage alors
que c'était prévu comme être une belle
année ont commencé à bien se faire
connaître en fin d'année les sociétés
aux alentours apprécié d'envoyer leurs
collaborateurs chez nous il ya une vraie
ambiance qui malheureusement a été coupé
avec le confinement je suis installé ça
fait un peu plus d'un an ici avec mon
épouse faut qu'on développe cette
affaire traînait un commerce d'utilité
local commerce de proximité
on est vraiment acteur local sur ce
plateau de saclay on est tombé sur une
période inédite d'eau sur l'ensemble du
territoire donc je suis pas le seul
mais c'est vrai qu'on est vraiment sur
une zone très tertiaire on a beaucoup de
sociétés autour de nous edf danone
thalès qui sont en télétravail l'edf à
100%
on a la chance d'avoir encore les
chantiers qui aujourd'hui on représente
énormément de flux pour nous je pense
que ce sera une zone vraiment vraiment
très convoité il faut juste passer la
tempête comme on dit après le après la
tempête
voilà le beau temps tout simplement
[Musique]